okay so this morning Brady sent me an
email and he said Oh check this out
something has happened so on Sunday it
was the Super Bowl I didn't know that
myself
I think Brady did you know it was the
super yes I stayed up and watched oh no
oh okay okay so apparently we have two
conferences we've got the NFC National
Football Conference we got the AFC the
American Football Conference and so
every year they have a team from each
conference and they play the Super Bowl
okay so for the last fourteen years the
previous 14 years the team that
represents the NFC have won the coin
toss
well it's externally it's certainly a
really unlikely event now unlikely
events happen so last Sunday this
winning streak of 14 wins that we had so
far was broken so last last Sunday it
was the AFC the team that represented
the AFC was it the Patriots the Patriots
won the coin toss so that's breaking our
streak of 14 successive wins they've
ended lose the game oh oh that's a shame
isn't it never mind okay yeah enough of
this football stuff right let's do some
maths right so we're going to work out
how long it would take to get that
streak of 14 in a row 14 wins in a row
right and so to make this a bit easier
we're not just going to dive into the
full thing we're not going to work out
14 wins in a row and make this a bit
easier I'm going to look at getting
three wins in a row we can work this out
if we can understand it the rest is easy
let's work out how long it would take to
get three wins in a row okay so this is
the odds of winning the coin toss not
the game no I could see Brady doing this
our phones give me the thumbs up it was
like yeah good right what I want to look
at first is let's look at getting three
wins or three winning three coin tosses
in a row
okay so first what's the probability of
getting those three wins this is quite
easy I think a lot of people can do this
themselves so we're looking for three
wins in a row win a probability of
winning the coin toss is a half so to
win one time is a half to win again you
times it by half again and then to win
three times your times by half okay so
one eighth of the time you could win
three coin tosses what about a streak of
four sequence of four because that means
you've lost and then you want one so
it's loss win win win now what's the
probability of that again not too hard
to work out half half half half one over
sixteen one sixteenth of the time you're
going to get a sequence of four games
that ends with win win win or four coin
tosses so what we're going to work out
is the average sequence the length of
the average sequence that ends with win
win win
why he was a sequence that was 5u that
means it could be like loss loss then
ends with win win win
or you could have a win then a loss win
win win for each of those the
probability is 1 over 32 but there's two
of them so altogether if your sequence
is five games
long it's 2 out of 32 so if you want to
work out the probability of a or the
average sequence length what you do is
you take the sequence lengths each
situation and multiply them by the
probability of getting that situation
now this is our waiting time this is how
long we want to wait for our win-win-win
now that it looks like you would have to
work out every single possible situation
every possible probability for that
situation multiply them all together
that would give you your average so that
would include all possible situations
like win win loss loss win win win
then it'll be win lost win-loss win loss
win win win so every single possible
situation and that does not sound like
fun so there's a really clever way to do
this and this is really clever right
I'll show you how to do this I'm going
to draw your little picture for this so
let's say you lose here and then win or
lose and win or lose here and win ok
I've shown you a little picture so
probability of losing is 1/2 losing your
coin toss probability of winning the
coin toss is 1/2 let's say we're looking
for the time we have to wait to get
these three wins in a row let's call
that T now in the first case I can
[ __ ] toss my coin and if I lose I'm
back to square one I've tossed a coin
and then I'm back I'll have to do it all
over again so the length of a series
I've tossed a coin then I'm back to
square one back to square one means I'm
back to this I'm back to waiting T games
for my sequence of three see that's how
long I would have to wait if I lose and
the probability of losing is 1/2 times
it by the probability that's what you
get the other situation is this you
could win then lose and back to square
one win and lose probability is 1/4 and
then you're back to square one where
you've tossed it once you've tossed the
coin twice and then you're back to
square
one that means you have to wait tea
again that's how many games you have to
wait or the third situation is you win
you win and then you lose and you're
back to square one
so what's the probability of that
happening that's an 8 then all three
coin tosses back to square one means 3
plus T or and the final situation is you
get it straight away win win win and the
probability of that is 1/8 and how long
did I have to wait 3 coin tosses win win
win and you've got your three wins in a
row fantastic you solve this this is
what you do you solve this formula it's
not that hard to solve you just multiply
that out mess around with it I can tell
you if you do solve it
the answer is T equals 14 this is the
average length that you would have to
wait the average number of games you
would have to wait to get three wins in
a row now if you want to do it in
general if you wanna do it for 14 pretty
much the same idea the same idea but in
general you get this T is equal to 2 to
the power M plus 1 minus 2 that is the
amount of time you would have to wait to
get n wins in a row
n wins n is going to be 14 for the
Superbowl in the Superbowl it was 14 so
if N equals 14 we're going to use this
and I can tell you the answer it was
thirty two thousand seven hundred and
sixty six we would have to play thirty
two thousand seven hundred and sixty-six
games before the last the average anyway
before you could expect to get fourteen
wins in a row that's the average mean
maybe it will take longer maybe you'll
get it straight away we don't know but
on average it's going to be about 32,000
games maybe 32,000 years
it only took 45 Super Bowls for them to
get 40 record tosses in a row though
yeah it did what happened so unlikely
events can happen unlikely events like
this can happen
like I said before we can toss as many
coins as we want it's not impossible
it's just unlikely so this isn't a
probability why I've worked out isn't a
probability this isn't the probability
of winning 14 times in a row this is the
length of time that we're going to wait
the number of games we're going to play
or the number of coin tosses we're going
to do until we get 14 wins in a row and
it's the average number and in the case
of the Super Bowl which happens only
once a year if you want this to happen
again then I would expect to wait 32,000
years
May 30 2016